les automobilistes devront redoubler de
vigilance dans tout villepreux la
limitation de vitesse passera à 30 km
heure à partir du 1er février 2019 ne
vais plus de 50% des rues qui étaient
déjà à 30
donc on a décidé pour une meilleure
lisibilité donc meilleure sécurité de
tous passés à 30 km heure mais on a
aussi une ville avait beaucoup de
familles à beaucoup d'enfants
on a beaucoup d'écoles beaucoup
d'assiettes maternelle donc de
poussettes on a un collège on a un lycée
donc étant une ville très familial il y
avait un réel problème sécuritaire ville
promet déjà bien équipée toutefois de
nouveaux panneaux de limitation de
vitesse seront installés dans la ville
on va mettre des panneaux d'entrée de
ville ça c'est très important de déjà de
d'annoncer dès qu'on rentre dans la
ville pour les villes provient et les
na'vi le prochain que la ville est à 30
donc voyez ça va être sur les entrées de
ville et bien évidemment rajouter
quelques bonnes notes dans la ville mais
c'est à la marge
attention aux contrôles ils seront
effectués par la police municipale
après une période de prévention on va
s'adapter par rapport à l'attitude des
villes provient je peux pas savoir
aujourd'hui si des villes projets vont
être très inciviques ou pas l'objectif
n'est pas de verbaliser l'objectif c'est
faire de la prévention de la pédagogie
plusieurs communes des yvelines ont déjà
fait le choix d'abaisser la limitation à
30 km heure
c'est le cas depuis trois ans à noisy le
roi la commune voisine de villepreux